Die nasa hat eine ziemliche horror meldung herausgegeben neue kartierungen zeigen
dass deutlich mehr gletscher grönlands von einer schmelze bedroht sind als bisher angenommen und das hat fatale folgen der meeresspiegel
wird stärker und schneller ansteigen als bisher vorhergesagt wie schlimm die lage wirklich ist und welche konsequenzen
schmelzende gletscher auch so in deutschland haben jetzt den klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ich kann leider nichts daran ändern der klimawandel kommt und er wird schlimm, so sieht es
Im moment aus die nasa hat gemeinsam mit 30 weiteren forschungseinrichtungen
Herausgefunden dass. Wo zwei bis viermal so viele gletscher grönlands von der schmelze gefährdet sind als man bislang
Angenommen hatte die neuen kartierungen sind so genau und detailreich wie nie zuvor und zeigen den meeresboden in
küstennähe sowie dem feld boden unter der eisdecke die aktuelle analyse basiert auf unfassbar vielen datenquellen wie
zb satelliten radar luftbilder
soldaten und die nasa kampagne omg also außen melting greenland hat
Daten geliefert eine menge die kartierung zeigen dass zwei bis vier mal so viele gletscher mehr als 200 meter unter die meeresoberfläche
Reichen als man bislang angenommen hatte die schmelze dieser teile der gletscher wird wohl nur minimal zum anstieg des meeresspiegels
beitrage obwohl sie über wasser kanals berg haben aber es gibt noch einen viel schlimmeren folgen effekt denn anders als
Die oberen 200 meter des meeres wasser sind die darunter liegenden, wasserschichten
vergleichsweise warm das liegt daran dass das tiefere meereswasser aus einer weiter
südlichen region in das gebiet strömt und somit bis zu vier grad wärmer ist als die oberen 200
Meter des meeres wasser heißt also
Im klartext gletscher die in diesen tieferen wärmeren teil des meeres reichen
schmelzen schneller nasa vertreter jobs will es sagt zitat diese ergebnisse zeigen dass das eis in grönland
Stärker vom klimawandel bedroht ist als wir erwartet hatten zitat ende
Die aktuelle nachricht der nasa kommt fast zeitgleich zur klimakonferenz in bonn wo rund
25.000 teilnehmer und teilnehmerinnen beraten wie man die erderwärmung auf unter zwei grad begrenzen kann
Im vergleich zur vorindustriellen zeit das zwei grad ziel ist sehr wichtig denn eine
Höhere durchschnittliche temperatur bedeutet nach meinung der meisten?
Forschungsteams einen gefährlichen klimawandels auch selbst eine geringere globale erwärmung hat wohl
dramatische konsequenzen für das eis in grönland berechnungen zufolge ist es schon heute, so dass die eisschmelze in grönland stärker zum anstieg des meeresspiegels
Beiträgt als die schmelze der antarktis eine komplett die gletscherschmelze grönlands hätte weitreichende folgen
Nach den neuen berechnungen würde der meeresspiegel dann. Um sieben meter 42 ansteigen und dabei hat jeder
einzelne gletscherabbruch ebenso wie die kontinuierliche gletscherschmelze direkten einfluss auf den anstieg des meeresspiegels
denn die großen gletscher halten das inlandeis quasi fest
Wenn diese umarmung also quasi wegschmilzt ist das so als würde man
einen korken aus einer flasche ziehen auch das inlandeis wird dann herausfließen und der meeresspiegel wird sehr viel
Höher ansteigen als prognosen bislang annehmen es gibt schätzungen nach denen dann bis zu einer?
Dreiviertel milliarde menschen weltweit betroffen werden und du wirst alle auch wenn grönland sehr weit von uns entfernt ist
Werden vor allem wie in deutschland aber auch die niederlande und belgien sehr stark betroffen seien genauso wie menschen in vielen anderen ländern dieser welt
Indonesien ägypten bangladesch oder thailand wenn der meeresspiegel nur um einen halben bis ganzen meter steigt würde der lebensraum zahlreicher
menschen komplett unter wasser stehen es gibt berechnungen nach denen bereits
Im jahr 2050 der prozess des abschmelzens unwiderruflichen gang gesetzt worden sein wird wenn sowohl das grönländische inlandeis
Und auch die antarktis eiskappe komplett schmelzen würden würde der meeresspiegel um 70 meter ansteigen 70 meter
eine unfassbare vorstellung jedenfalls zeigen alle modellrechnungen dass alle weltweit meist vollkommen sehr sensibel auf die globale klimaerwärmung
reagieren an dieser stelle können wir uns schon mal schön selbst an die nase fassen wenn feststeht der
klimawandel wird zum weitaus größten teil durch uns
verursacht durch die industrienationen genau dies haben us behörden jetzt noch, mal
In einem bericht bekräftigt in ihrem thema bericht beziehen sich die autoren und autorinnen
Auch auf dem meeresspiegel sie warnen davor dass er noch bis zum jahr
2100 um bis zu zwei meter 40 ansteigen könnte also wir sind gar nicht, so betroffen aber umso mehr die nächsten generationen
Im klartext heißt das also das klima ist noch lange nicht gerettet
Im gegenteil und bei den koalitionsverhandlungen berlin tun sie im moment alles dafür damit die rettung in weite ferne deshalb unterschreibt das
generationen manifest damit die zukunft besser wird und nicht schlechter heartless dabei mesalliance
Hätte früher eckart von hirschhausen und viele viele mehr hier ist der link
Unbedingt mitmachen ich zähle auf euch hier geht es weiter mit politik zerstört die erde da habe
ich den letzten video mal etwas dampf abgelassen und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran